you know everyone knows that I was ill I
had cancer and when I was a treated in
the hospital that's why you know this
illness is a mercy from God to bring
people back to him and in reality
well I Allah is my witness God is my
witness I felt sorry for those who do
not believe in God because I saw them
three people around me died and you know
those who claim that they are atheist I
said come here and you can realize that
there is God I heard God help me God
help me God is a mercy for us this is a
message for non-muslims wa alaikum
Salaam
this is a lead our this today is the
meeting not over there follows because
he's your father your mother I can sense
now we know we say in Arabic the ship lo
medical asset yeah this ship will ship
young yes from this life but let me
embarrass you in front of the camera so
he says that he has been trying to get
in touch with me for how many years
no no I tried one time yeah yeah just
say this one time yes one time so just
my intention the offense that it was
you're here a state one time we spoke
number one we spoke yes yeah we spoke it
was my mistake so I wasn't trying like
constantly Zach but I what I meant would
you say was I had the intention I wanted
to at least the intention is there yeah
because the action of the intention of
the believer is better than I was
studying the main reasons for success
from management perspective from an
Islamic perspective because I studied
management a lot as well and I like
management and I found that there are
three key reasons for success first of
all the clarity of vision second second
one commitment for that way and third
one networking with people who share
with you that vision these three
mentioned by all books of managers and
subhanAllah you find that those the
three have been heavily mentioned in
Quran and Sunnah and distressed on the
first one clarity of vision is the
intention the first editions il Bihari
is what intention actions are judged by
intention intention is another form of
vision what do you want to do what you
want to achieve this is your intention
second one which is commitment is
actually sober sober is not the negative
sober that we understand it is the
positive sober could commitment
perseverance yeah
as the professor Salem says a sob rudia
a sober is enlightenment
yeah so this is the second reason for or
the second factor for success and the
third one is networking with others who
share with you this region which is
where unity and you see sherry as
stressed a lot on work on unity Wow just
immovable allahi jami amulet
yeah hold all of you up on the Rope of
Allah Allah Allah and don't be this
United brothers sisters for your success
have a vision be committed to achieve
that vision with commitment in your life
in general and the third thing be a
person of unity be part of a Jamaa and
be part of the Ummah first I'm not yet
Muslims out there they heard you say
this word Sharia and some people their
neck is the hairs on the neck are
standing now because now they're
programmed to think so the boogeyman has
come again
surely I simply means Islam as simple as
this and by the way Shariah are you find
it everywhere including America people
are praying according to Sharia isn't it
women are wearing hijab according to
Sharia yeah so this is part of Islam
people think wrongly non-muslims think
that Sharia is a limited toward cutting
the hands of the thief etc etcetera
etcetera
no this is not Sharia love is part of
Sharia you know sometimes in my
teachings I say to people when they make
mistakes mistakes I will punish you
according to Sharia yeah then I say come
come I will deal with you according to
Sharia and then the person comes and I
have yeah we said what is this I said
love in fact love is a main element of
Sharia justice is the main element
social justice Allah Allah says in the
Quran in allaha ya'muru bil Oliva you
will carry well body here a locum la
allakum to the Quran Allah enjoins us to
establish what justice or Allah enjoins
justice
and if that means going beyond justice
which is what to do
mercy to have mercy and to apply mercy
on people and then treating your
relatives with more kindness is it true
that now the Penal Code which lot of the
Islamophobes they try to scare people
with that it only makes her what about
is it true 1% of the Quran what the
hadoo the punishment the Penal Code this
is all part of its more very tiny part
of Islam yeah and why because now to be
honest with you wherever I travel
Islamism rise people are looking for
solutions people they want spiritual
guidance they want a spiritual
treatments to spiritual medicine you
know we all know that they say in 2030
or something 20 the main illness in the
world is what mental illnesses yeah what
those mental illnesses what is the main
cure for those mental illnesses
connection with Allah put the greater
isn't it true that in the Bible you I
mean when you open up the Arabic Bible
surely as in there didn't you think
Moses bring the city yeah because he has
the word Chania means no means my way
yeah that way this is the world Sharia
yeah so doesn't you people should not be
scurred or have Sharia phobia or
something like this they should not have
something like so Jesus brought it Moses
brought it and the last and final
masters of the mankind problem Hamid
peace and blessings be upon him he's a
prophet for all America even them
the Quran the Quran says many places
yeah Johannes is auditing the entire
Bangkok yeah the Quran did not come for
Muslims for believers for certain people
for everyone to give them guidance and
to give them hope and so that's why you
know if I may just turn
yes what is the word - ship I you know
everyone knows that I was ill I had
cancer and when I was a treated in the
hospital you had chemotherapy if you
know about chemotherapy
I lost my bid I lost my energy I lost a
lot of weight it drives you crazy
yes yeah in the middle of the night you
are ill you are tired you are down you
are suffering from all types of problems
and you don't know whether you are going
to be cured you are going to die you
have pain from one side you don't know
what is happening to our family etc etc
what are you going to do you wake up in
the middle of the night because of pain
what are you going to do you need
someone who is powerful to talk to him
to take your girl and anxiety to
complain to him and not only that if you
know that very well someone who is the
most powerful one he is your Creator and
he listens not he just know he listens
and he will help you he's the only one
to help you that will put a lot of peace
in your heart and that's why you know
this illness is a mercy from God to
bring people back to him and in reality
well I Allah is my witness God is my
witness I felt sorry for those who do
not believe in God because I saw them
three people around me died yes one
person died just the night before when
they brought him he was totally finished
and they were giving him morphine very
high dose of morphine anti-violent a
pain painkillers
I think anyway whatever his name was no
one will help you except God I just want
to help them you turn a knob because you
love yeah I felt sorry for them yeah and
you know those who claim that they are
atheist I said come here and you can
realize that there is God once you are
in that situation so this person in the
middle of the night Allah is my witness
he used to wake up and he used to say
God I heard God help me god help me this
is the natural disposition and then the
second day he passed away we need God
God is a mercy for us this is a message
for non-muslims listen guys do whatever
you want to do for Muslims Muslims will
flourish Islam is the religion of this
position you are not going if the entire
world yeah gather together against Islam
and Muslims they will not be able to
finish Islam and Muslims in fact every
time they come against Islam and Muslims
Islam will flourish more and more here
we are in Bosnia now yeah there was the
war against Muslims Muslims after the
war they are better than Muslims before
the world when the war yes or no yes or
no everyone I visited was here 10 years
ago and now I see Bosnia much better
than 10 years ago yeah subhanAllah the
war brought people back to Islam so if
you want to wait wars against us I don't
want to say thank you yeah but you are
in reality bringing people back to Islam
whatever you do against Islam because it
is the religion of the most powerful one
God so I'm not worried from this
perspective I am not worried at all
Islam will continue flourishing I see
this rule ah I see this that's why I'm
overconfident about this I have no
problem
let alone that Quran confirmed God
himself confirmed it I really feel sorry
for non-muslims because they need God in
their life they need God they need
someone to empower them spiritually
socially intellectually for them to face
the challenges of this life and no one
can empower them to face the challenges
of this life like God him only that's it
let alone I want all of them to go to
paradise with us so we enjoy the luxury
of paradise and last thing maybe we took
long time I said to many non-muslims you
know intellectuals academics journalists
show me one thing that is wrong in Islam
one thing what does wrong mean one thing
in Islam that is harmful one thing that
is really harmful I say to them okay
another thing I say to them I can
discuss this with you okay but give me
another thing Oh
they what they say what about Sharia I
said all of you if you are intellectuals
and academics you know that if they are
talking about punishments that those
punishments deter what crime and where
there are some harsh punishment the
crime rate goes down David Cameron
himself when his bike was stolen he was
very angry yeah and he said next time
I'll bring Sharia Google that you will
find it it is yeah
what does it means deep down he
understand that these harsh punishments
will stop such crimes okay so even Louis
rules they are not
they did not come to harm people they
came to bring peace to people I
challenge anyone and let any non-muslim
accept my challenge through your channel
to bring one thing one thing that is
harmful but we need to discuss it
intellectually not just - oh yeah well
Sharia says this about homosexuals or
Islam says this about legal punishments
or we want intellectual discussion so
you intellectually discuss academically
to see the context things are anything
that is harmful everything in Islam is
for the benefit of humanity because it's
from the divine it's from because it is
from the divine yeah beautiful inside I
ever hear in bars that we couldn't plan
this better allows the best of planners
many Kaju at one yeah okay
wa alaikum Salaam
this is Ali Dawa this is Eddie I'm
taking messages for for the Sheikh can I
go ahead and take one yes can I take a
message
are you ollie Dawa are you the guy that
gives a lot of Dawa are you friends with
a guy named hijab is what's this for
Mohammed hijab is he the one that puts
the put you in a pretzel lock with the
jujitsu oh this is Eddie right you know
who this is yeah how you doing
how you good good we did a little prank
on you
how's everything good yeah yeah we're
together we're together learning from
you now he said one of them yeah
his father is passing away and he's
taking selfie next to his father and say
oh yeah my father is he said mixed are
for your father
we got our brothers from London the UK
inside I've all accepted Islam 25 years
ago yeah you're making me sound old no
hey hey hey 25 years I won five years
ago
yeah after investigating for about a
year and a half that's right yeah yeah I
was looking through medida videos I was
watching debates between different
people reading books on and off I'm not
saying I was doing every single day but
that was in 1993 and yeah I got to a
stage where there was no longer a choice
for me under you look when you see Pete
you've been dedicated yeah what has been
a key to your dedication and now how do
you feel when you see people coming in
and now some unfortunately leaving Islam
what advice do you have for them and
when you see this what comes what
thoughts flow through your mind
I mean dedication is a big word I mean I
hope that a large that accepts from all
that we do but the the best thing that
can dispel all of those kind of things
is really just simple knowledge
knowledge just the importance of
knowledge which still will dispel these
kind of trouble hurt is you know these
doubts that appear these doubts are who
was new and doubts was appearing so the
importance of knowledge and behaving
they being able to just get rid of those
doubts Australia we're not allowing them
to fester in your mind to build in your
mind to then complete create confusion
and whatnot so you know being with
people of knowledge and studying and
seek and allows how all times the best
way inside I started to try and you know
keep reminds me of the hadith where the
Prophet SAW said that the knowledgeable
person darling the scholar you know is
heavier and Shaitaan than a thousand is
that right a thousand worshipping you
know they said yeah I mean it's also
that you know the example of the atom is
the example of the scholar is the
example of the full moon at the night
yeah I know the servants are like smooth
to us yeah so the impact of a
knowledgeable person is so much greater
than a person who is
just a normal servant you know
everyone's gonna become a scholar you
know that's that's acceptable but at
least have the basic knowledge in that
already solid that the basics on your
foundation exactly because if the
foundation is strong a house would be
strong yeah foundation is weak you got a
crumble exactly because you know she
upon and his army and his should will
heard these doubts are constantly
fighting us and if you don't have
something in between yourself and that
maybe one day something just enters your
mind and then causes you to just go on
us you know by party no strange person
misguided posture